Os voy a hacer una confesion: de mayor quiero
ser como BRUCE DICKINSON, el cantante de Iron
Maiden. Y de paso, os doy un consejo, si tenéis
la oportunidad de escuchar a la Doncella en
directo, no lo dejéis pasar porque realmente
merece la pena. Aquí salimos mi hermano y
yo, en el a–o 2016 cuando yo conservaba el
pelo… Pero volvamos al se–or Bruce Dickinson.
No contento con ser el cantante de heavy metal
más emblemático de todos los tiempos, el
Sr. Dickinson es también locutor de radio,
piloto de aviones y presidente de una de las
empresas más modernas de aviación.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué tiene que ver Iron
Maiden con la política? ¿Por qué os hablamos
de Bruce Dickinson en VisualPolitik? Pues…
la razón no es otra que esta.
El cantante de Iron Maiden, Bruce Dickinson,
y su empresa CARDIFF AVIATION firman un acuerdo
para gestionar las aerolíneas nacionales
de Yibuti
Cardiff Aviation es una empresa del mantenimiento
de aviones comerciales. Podríamos decir que
Iron Maiden ha aterrizado en Yibuti pero,
en este caso, llegaron para vender aviones,
entrenar a los pilotos y diseñar todo el
sistema para que ahora, las aerolíneas de
este país, Air Djibouti, puedan funcionar
por su cuenta.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque aquí llega
lo realmente importante! Pensaréis que las
líneas aéreas de un país como YIBUTI no
son gran cosa ¿Verdad? Se trata de un país
pobre, situado en el cuerno de África y con
una población que ni siquiera llega al millón
de habitantes. Sin embargo… ¿Y si os dijera
que Yibuti tiene todas las posibilidades de
convertirse en el nuevo Dubai? ¿Y si Bruce
Dickinson fuera uno de los primeros visionarios
que decide invertir en este país? Pensadlo
bien y fijaos en el mapa. Esto de aquí es
Yibuti, esto de aquí es el canal de SUEZ
y esto otro es el Mar Rojo. Por ejemplo, cualquier
barco petrolero que quiera salir de Abu Dhabi
con destino a Europa tiene que pasar por el
Mar Rojo. Esos teléfonos móviles chinos
que compramos en España, también viajan
por el Mar Rojo. En total, 1 de cada 10 barcos
mercantes que viajan por el mundo, pasa por
las costas de Yibuti ¡Y no os creáis que
es un mar tranquilo! ¿Habéis oído hablar
de los piratas somalíes? Pues Somalia es
esto de aquí. Y esto otro es Eritrea, que
tampoco es precisamente un remanso de paz
y tranquilidad. Y esto de aquí es Yemen,
que está en guerra ¡Resulta que Yibuti es
el único país pacífico que encontramos
en esta zona! ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que ETIOPÍA es uno de los países
que más rápido está creciendo en todo el
planeta. Se está consolidando como toda una
potencia en el sector textil. Y tiene más
de 90 millones de habitantes ¿Y sabéis qué?
¡Etiopía no tiene salida al mar! Es decir,
que si quieren exportar la ropa que fabrican,
no les queda otro remedio que hacerlo a través
del Puerto de Yibuti.
Y ya sé lo que os estáis preguntando ahora…
¿De verdad estamos ante un nuevo Singapur
o hay gato encerrado? ¿Deberíamos imitar
a Bruce Dickinson y ponernos a invertir en
este país? Hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
ESTAR EN EL SITIO INDICADO
Después de todo lo que os he contado sobre
Yibuti, muchos estaréis pensando que cómo
es posible que no hayamos oído hablar antes
de este país ¿Verdad? La respuesta es que
la historia y la política yibutiense no es
muy distinta que la de sus vecinos. En el
año 1977, tras un referendum pacífico, Yibuti
se convirtió en el último país en independizarse
de sus colonos franceses. Y como ocurrió
en otros casos parecidos, Yibuti se convirtió
en una dictadura de partido único. Hasta
los años 90, el señor HASSAN GOULED APTIDON
y los miembros de su tribu controlaron los
designios del país. Las torturas a los miembros
de la oposición se convirtieron en una práctica
habitual mientras el partido del gobierno
se hacía rico con los beneficios del puerto.
Por aquellos años, Yibuti era un ejemplo
de libro de lo que expertos llaman un “GATE-KEEPER
STATE”. Perdonad por la palabrota en inglés
pero es que es un término tan específico
que no tiene traducción en español. Veréis,
en estos países tan pobres, toda la economía
se centra en un único recurso. En el caso
de Guinea Ecuatorial, por ejemplo, es el petróleo.
En el caso de Yibuti, es el puerto. Y como
los dictadores no tienen dinero como para
pagar a un ejército que controle todo el
país, tienen que concentrar todo su aparato
represor en lo que les importa.
Eso explica que el puerto de Yibuti estuviera
perfectamente controlado pero que el resto
del país fuera un auténtico caos, con asesinatos
en las calles, violaciones y toda clase de
barbaridades.
Como os podéis imaginar, esta no es la situación
idónea para crear empresas ni atraer la inversión
extranjera.
Y para colmo, en los años 90, estalló una
guerra civil entre el gobierno y las tribus
y partidos de la oposición.
Y aquí es donde llega la primera diferencia
entre Yibuti y otros países de la zona: el
modo en el que se resolvió el conflicto.
Básicamente, tras varios años de lucha y
miles de bajas en ambos lados, el señor Aptidon
se acercó al principal partido enemigo, el
“Movimiento por la Regeneración Democrática
y el Progreso” y les dijo “¡Mirad chicos!
Aquí hay dinero para todos así que ¿Por
qué no nos repartimos el poder y dejamos
de pelearnos?”.
Y así es como Yibuti tuvo su primer gobierno
de concentración. Un gobierno que engloba
a prácticamente todos los partidos políticos.
Por supuesto, siguen existiendo partidos de
la oposición. Pero a duras penas pueden hacer
campaña y siempre que hay elecciones presidenciales,
intentan boicotearlas. Eso significa que el
señor HASSAN GOULED APTIDON y, más tarde,
su sobrino, OMAR GUELLEH, ganan las elecciones
por resultados cercanos al 100% del voto.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto es sólo
el principio! Pese a resolver sus luchas internas,
en el año 2001, Yibuti seguía siendo un
país corrupto y, sobretodo, con una posición
muy débil. Pensadlo bien… hablamos de un
sitio muy pequeño, con menos de 1 millón
de habitantes, que está en el medio de una
de las regiones más violentas del planeta.
A un lado tienen a Somalia, que en la práctica
es una anarquía donde distintas tribus se
matan entre sí. Al otro lado tienen a Eritrea,
que está considerada como la dictadura más
salvaje del planeta. Y en el Sur tienen a
Etiopía, que es la mayor potencia en la región
y que, en cualquier momento, podría querer
invadir Yibuti para tener salida al mar.
Vamos, que no estaban ni de lejos en una situación
tranquila. Y entonces, cuando todo parecía
estar en su contra, la historia decidió sonreír
a los yibutienses…
SUBS “Nuestros enemigos son una red de terroristas
radicales y todos los gobiernos que les apoyan”
De repente, Estados Unidos, con George Bush
de presidente, declara la guerra al terrorismo.
Y eso implica mandar tropas a todas las zonas
donde hay células de Al Qaeda, lo cual incluye
el Cuerno de África ¿Y qué mejor lugar
para construir una base militar que Yibuti?
La localización es perfecta y, a pesar de
que su gobierno es corrupto y viola los derechos
humanos, al menos es estable y no tiene vínculos
con los terroristas.
¿Recordáis que os decía que el Mar Rojo
es peligrosísimo para los barcos mercantes?
Pues desde la base de Camp Lemmonier, los
estadounidenses pueden perseguir a los piratas
somalíes ¡Y no sólo los estadounidenses!
En sólo 10 años, la lista de países que
han desplegado fuerzas en Yibuti es interminable.
Podemos encontrar tropas francesas, italianas
y españolas. Para que os hagáis una idea,
la única base militar que tiene Japón en
territorio extranjero, está en este país.
Y, por supuesto, con tanta potencia internacional
poniendo bases militares… ¡China tampoco
se iba a perder esta fiesta!
China abre su primera base extranjera en Yibuti
Y, por supuesto, en un país tan pobre y tan
pequeño, tener tantísimas bases militares
supone un auténtico espaldarazo para su economía.
Todos esos soldados necesitan comer en algún
sitio, hacer la compra y salir a divertirse.
Eso significa más trabajos y muchísimo más
dinero para el país entero.
Pero, por encima de todo, elimina el mayor
problema que tenía Yibuti para poder atraer
la inversión. Con tantísimas bases militares
en el país, nadie en su sano juicio se atrevería
a invadirles. Ahora mismo, hay pocos lugares
más seguros en África que Yibuti.
Si a eso le sumamos su situación perfecta
en las rutas comerciales internacionales,
es fácil entender por qué este país ha
estado creciendo a un ritmo del 5% desde el
momento en el que el ejército estadounidense
puso los pies en el lugar.
Sin embargo, y como decimos siempre, no todo
es tan bonito. Pese a todo ese crecimiento,
Yibuti continúa con un paro de más del 50%.
Sí, sí, habéis oído bien… 50%. Y a día
de hoy, el puerto de Yibuti y las bases militares
son la única fuente de riqueza del país.
En otras palabras, que las aerolíneas que
ayudó a crear nuestro amigo Bruce Dickinson,
se limitan a transportar a militares y cooperantes
que tienen que viajar a lugares como Somalia
o Etiopía.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
pueden cambiar! Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN HOMBRE CON UNA VISIÓN
Quedaos con este nombre, ILYAS MOUSSA DAWALEH.
Diréis ¿Es el nuevo presidente de Yibuti?
¡No! ¡Para nada! Yibuti continúa con el
mismo presidente que tenía hace 20 años.
Este es el ministro de finanzas. Pero, en
este caso, el ministro de finanzas es incluso
más conocido que su presidente.
“Necesitábamos un plan a largo plazo. Entendemos
que lo más probable es que no consigamos
alcanzar nuestros objetivos durante esta administración,
pero Visión 2035 marca los objetivos para
el Presidente y su Gobierno”
--ILYAS MOUSSA DAWALEH.
Si lleváis suscritos a VisualPolitik desde
hace algún tiempo, esto de Vision 2035 os
sonará de algo ¿Recordáis este vídeo en
el que os hablaba del desarrollo de Ruanda?
Pues sí, es un calco en muchos aspectos.
El gobierno de Yibuti quiere que sus puertos
tengan la mejor tecnología y sean comparables
a los de Singapur o Dubai y para eso necesitan
dinero ¡Pero no sólo eso! Dawaleh es consciente
de para que una economía funcione, es fundamental
diversificar. Si sólo dependemos de un único
sector económico o de una única empresa,
una pequeña crisis puede hundir al país
entero.
Sin embargo, para eso necesitas dinero y,
sobretodo, un entorno que permita la creación
de negocios. La corrupción y la falta de
estado de derecho no se lleva muy bien con
la inversión extranjera. Y en eso, Yibuti
se lleva la medalla de oro. Para que os hagáis
una idea, pese a que el puerto sea el gigante
económico de todo el país, apenas hay información
contable disponible. Eso significa que muchos
oficiales del gobierno se están llevando
dinero a menos llenas sin que nadie pueda,
siquiera, enterarse. Por si esto fuera poco,
parte de su legislación está basada en la
SHARIA. Y nadie puede protestar por todo esto
porque Yibuti está entre los 10 países con
menos libertad de expresión del mundo. Sin
ir más lejos, en 2016, el Gobierno encarceló
a 3 periodistas de la BBC que iban a cubrir
los fraudes electorales.
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto lastra
bastante las posibilidades de este país.
Y lo que es peor ¡Es prácticamente imposible
cambiar el sistema! La clase dirigente ya
gana suficiente dinero con el puerto y los
alquileres que cobran a los ejércitos extranjeros
por tener las bases militares. Y, precisamente
por eso mismo, tienen suficiente seguridad
como para no tener miedo a ningún levantamiento
popular.
En otras palabras, que si el señor Moussa
Dawaleh, ministro de finanzas de Yibuti, quería
cambiar el sistema político y, como dice
en su propio documento, Visión 2035, “mejorar
la gobernanza del país”, lo tenía bastante
crudo ¿Verdad? Pues… mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, a veces los milagros ocurren.
Yibuti empieza a construir una enorme zona
de libre comercio respaldada por China
Dicho de otra forma: si no puedes cambiar
todo el sistema político de tu país… limítate
a cambiar, únicamente, un trocito del mismo.
En esta zona económica especial, cualquiera
podrá comprar terrenos y construir sin necesidad
de esperar meses y meses para conseguir un
permiso del gobierno. Y, por supuesto, esto
elimina las tentaciones para exigir sobornos.
Por otra parte, todas las regulaciones van
a seguir la ley china. Es algo así como una
pequeña Shenzhen en mitad del país.
Según el acuerdo, esta zona manejará 7000
millones de dólares en comercio dentro de
dos años. Yibuti eliminará los controles
aduaneros con China y establecerá un centro
de tránsito con un sistema de cambio de divisas
simplificado.
¿Y qué cabe esperar a partir de ahora? Pues
bien, la idea de las zonas económicas especiales
no es nada nuevo. Y ha demostrado que funciona.
Es, de hecho, el mismo sistema que permitió
que Dubai sea la metrópoli que es hoy en
día. La idea es que cuando tienes una zona
económica especial, tanto los ciudadanos
como las élites políticas tienen un escaparate
de lo que ocurre cuando se tienen leyes transparentes
y ventajas para las empresas. Si este experimento
funcionara, las élites políticas del país
estarán mucho más dispuestas a hacer cambios
reales en el resto de Yibuti.
En resumen, que tenemos un país africano
cuya seguridad está, prácticamente, garantizada
por los ejércitos de todo el mundo y que
está empezando a hacer reformas serias. Un
país que tiene la ubicación y el tamaño
perfecto para convertirse en centro financiero
y logístico de uno de los puntos más transitados
en el comercio internacional. Parece que el
señor Bruce Dickinson ha encontrado un nuevo
paraíso virgen para la inversión.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no significa
que Yibuti vaya a convertirse en ningún oasis
de libertad y derechos humanos! A fin de cuentas,
ni China ni Dubai lo son. Ahora bien, puede
que esto sea el comienzo del fin de la pobreza
en esta zona.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que se cumplirán
las predicciones? ¿Es ahora un buen momento
para invertir en Yibuti o tal vez se quedará
todo en buenas palabras?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y si queréis conocer por qué Dubai es tan
rico, haced click en este enlace ¡Os doy
una pista! ¡No tiene nada que ver con el
petróleo!
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perdeos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto!